the award for best actor will be
presented by a young lady who flew in
all the way from Europe a very gracious
and wonderful thing to do but then you
expect gracious and wonderful things
when the presenter is Miss Audrey
heurn
thank you very much the nominees for the
best performance by an actor are Richard
Burton in
Becket GRE Harrison and my My Fair
Lady Peter o in
Becket Anthony Quinn in Zorba the
Greek and Peter Sellers and dror Strange
Love or how I learn to stop woring and
love the
B the winner
is
Rick
[Music]
harison
well this is a very exciting evening for
me and I feel in a way that I should
spit it in
half I uh I would like to thank
everybody that
had um anything to do with with the
making of My Fair Lady it was a
wonderful experience and I must thank
George for being so marvelous with us
and and Jack and everybody else was
connected with it and deep love to
uh well two Fair ladies I think yes all
meaz
take
goodbye